could Elvis be destined for the deserts
of arrakis just as cost and Butler whose
iconic draw doesn't seem to be going
anywhere anytime soon but in the end you
got to listen to yourself
well I want you to know those New York
people Ain't Gonna Change Me Not
the Golden Globes returned on January
10th to celebrate the 80th anniversary
of the all-encompassing entertainment
awards ceremony this year the Golden
Globes awarded well-deserved television
and Film nominees such as the side
splitting gem Abbott Elementary
legendary black panther wakanda forever
actress Angela Bassett and the dazzling
star Austin Butler for a show-stopping
performance as Elvis Presley
mumbling and coherently to the audience
was a good show Colonel I know when I'm
excited an audience Butler's fateful
portrayal of Elvis skyrocketed the
success of banslerman's biopic with an
ear perfect audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes This launched the film to an
impressive Global box office take of 287
million dollars Among The Summer's
competitive slate with one award already
under his glistening belt it's safe to
say he now has an even better chance of
securing the Oscar in March uh
everything's happening so fast in the
last year and a half till uh I'm almost
up you know I mean I can't keep up with
everything that's happened when Butler
came on stage to receive his award for
Elvis His voice sounded astonishingly
similar to The Beloved musician using a
rich baritone and slight twang that's
reminiscent of his film portrayal as it
turns out the actor has some surprising
thoughts about that resemblance speaking
with People magazine Butler broke down
the parallels between himself and Elvis
and offered some explanation as to why
they might sound similar he even
detailed a meaningful relationship he
shares with the Presley family which
culminated in his authentic
representation of the iconic star
backstage at the bustling award show
Butler told reporters that he doesn't
hear Elvis in his own voice however he
didn't shoot down the possibility that
the performance has stayed with him
given how long he spent playing Elvis I
had three years where that was my only
focus in life so I'm sure that there's
just pieces of my DNA that will always
be linked in that way Butler has been
open about his special connection with
Elvis that led him to the part the
acclaimed actor also expressed his
gratitude and thanked the Presley family
for their blessing and encouragement all
you have to do is come through social
media to find a ton of comments from
fans and point out how different Austin
Butler's voice has been since Elvis and
in fact his recent interviews aren't the
first time the actor referenced it
Butler previously addressed the vocal
similarity on a Saturday Night Live
debut in December 2022 during his
opening monologue he spoke about how
people had been talking about his
alleged new voice that it got deeper
more Elvis but that's not true I've
always sounded like this and I can prove
it he then transitioned to an interview
clip from 10 years ago with one Small
Change how excited are you to be
Sebastian on the Carrie diary I'm really
excited it's been a great experience so
far it's clear he's willing to have some
fun with his Fame and any criticism that
may come his way but will Austin
Butler's voice ever go back to the way
it was only time will tell but one thing
is for certain with Butler slated for a
role in Dune part two it sure would be
interesting to see if Elvis impersonator
turn up on arrakis
[Music]